that's when you say you're lying jacob
being spider-man is hard work all that
power all that responsibility all that
time on set squeezing in and out of
those suits and hanging in the air oof
and of course the harder something is
the easier it is to goof up let's take a
look at some of the greatest bloopers
and blown takes from 20 years of
spider-man films
in a recent interview tom holland talked
about how much harder it was to shoot
the stunt heavy uncharted instead of his
action being mostly green screened in
the marvel films but like we said being
spider-man is a ton of physical work
even in the age of super realistic cgi
so let's look at him getting swung
around and taking tumbles in that iconic
suit you really like the suit right i do
yes
because i can go to the bathroom in it
mainly in the 2004 spider-man 2 director
sam raimi always in love with physical
effects chose to make doc ox tentacles
large practical puppets that swung
around the actor interacting with him
and picking up and manipulating objects
even the most precise puppets can be
hard to finesse though as seen in these
botched takes where they were supposed
to bring a glass to actor alfred
molina's lips and let him take a sip i'm
driving
i think we all know by now not to mess
with samuel l jackson he's been bringing
his distinct menacing aura to movies and
credit card commercials for almost 50
years and has a well-earned reputation
as a real pro who always hits his mark
and knows his lines
we think that has earned him the right
to not have his lines stepped on by
anyone or anything as tom holland
learned here when he snapped a prop shot
during a take on spider-man far from
home we're almost there
shut the thing on my line
these days sam raimi is probably best
known as the writer and director of the
original spider-man trilogy and as the
director of the upcoming doctor strange
sequel but his origins as a scrappy
director of the indie horror evil dead
films still show through in his love for
getting hands on during shooting like in
this shot from the original spider-man
where he made sure that he was the one
to really nail peter parker in the head
with a heavy backpack
while we're on the topic of sam raimi it
would be a shame if we didn't show off
just how much glee he takes in
tormenting his cast and crew even
getting his producers involved in
elaborate stunt pieces in these shots
from spider-man 3 where sandman is
ripping off an armored car the guard is
played by producer grant curtis who
stuck it out like a champ even as the
director buried him in tons of sand over
and over again
it's exciting
finally let's close out our own rainy
trilogy of bloopers with this bit of
test footage where he delivers a touch
of familial abuse on his little brother
ted there's a pre-frame for him
[Music]
truly nobody can burn you or annoy you
like family even on a big budget film
set wow sam
harsh ah pigeons the majestic plentiful
trash birds of urban centers the whole
world over did you know that pigeons
produce a kind of thin cheese-like
substance in their throats that they use
to feed their young if you didn't well
we're profoundly sorry it's very
possible that zendaya knows all sorts of
horrible pigeon facts though it would
certainly explain her kind of freaking
out while she was being covered in
pigeons on the set of spider-man far
from
home there's so many
being an actor can be pretty tough all
those lines all those takes the bright
lights of the set and sometimes your
john paxton who didn't start acting
until he was 70. the father of actor
bill paxton john started working with
sam raimi on 1998's a simple plan and
landed himself a plum role as osborne's
personal valet in the spider-man trilogy
unfortunately the poor guy also had to
deliver this clunker of a line in
spider-man 3 which he couldn't seem to
get out no matter what angle they shot
him from came from his gilder
okay his glider that's right or where he
had been placed on the set the blade
that pierced his body
came from his trailer
we can't blame him any we'd probably
blow that line too
tony revolori's version of flash
thompson has been a refreshing take on
spider-man's traditional high school
foil giving him a little pathos and
plenty of privilege without having to
turn the character into a cruel meat
head he's a great present so far in the
homecoming trilogy with his weirdly
charmed life but one thing that didn't
come easily to him is this line reading
and far from home how much blood did you
donate to the zip up up why does it
where he's pestering peter parker about
just how much blood the poor kid had to
sell to get on the class's european trip
gather around and hear a tale of the old
internet when posting this picture of
tobey maguire was comedy gold it seems
almost like an impossible image with
maguire somehow making his mouth tiny
while turning it into a deep v-shaped
smile to be honest we always thought it
was photoshop wizardry but then we
watched the blooper reel for spider-man
3 and discovered that uh wow he actually
made that face
toby maguire has a way more elastic face
than we thought we kind of can't turn
away
for almost 40 years greek fashion
designer john varvatos has helped men
look like they're on their way to a very
expensive rock concert for a band you've
never even heard of honestly it's kind
of a tony stark look so imagine our
surprise when we were watching the
bloopers for far from home and saw this
take that could have completely changed
how we saw the film's villain mysterio i
had a
sick closet full of mostly john
varvafatos
now we can't stop imagining an alternate
reality where quentin beck rocks the
styles of the architect of all his pain
there's no sense in mourning what might
have been but maybe in no way home for
the first and third entry in the raimi
trilogy of spider-man films there was
nothing like watching willem dafoe
embody norman osborne and the green
goblin he's a compelling screen presence
to begin with but he threw himself into
the role of osborne with entrancing
gusto imagine our surprise when we
learned that the guy only loved doing
two things on blown takes making weird
noises in his green goblin voice and
doing menacing voguing
there's not a whole lot to say about
this one other than that tom holland and
jake gyllenhaal seem like really fun
guys who can't quite figure out how
shaking hands works
this i don't think the shot works it
can't be that hard right we're not sure
we've been social distancing for a while
shaking hands fills us at least a little
bit with dread now
maybe we don't shake hands just do this
thank you
okay so we may have already covered the
puppet assisted comedy of alfred molina
as auto octavius but this one is just
too good to leave out during his
starring heel turn in spider-man 2
molina was also in preparations to lead
a stage production of fiddler on the
roof taking the lead in a major musical
is daunting work so the actor would
occasionally practice between takes for
the cast and crew thankfully the
puppeteers were also ready to get
involved giving us this gem where dr
octopus himself does a bit of if i were
a rich man
if i were a rich man
the homecoming universe of spider films
has seen some major changes for the
character and how he is presented for
one thing we never get a death scene for
uncle ben and for another the films
don't have the same obsession with peter
parker's parents as the amazing
spider-man films did at least not in any
of the takes they used it turns out that
tom holland has a habit of breaking
character and saying the quiet parts of
his take on spider-man's past very loud
my parents are dead
well this has been plenty of fun but now
to take us out how about we celebrate 20
years of spider-man actors sneezing in
the middle of takes gazoon tied everyone
we know those are hard to keep in
i'm so sorry
and there you have it mayhem mishaps and
plenty of falling over and flood lines
what are some of your favorite spider
bloopers sound off in the comments and
thanks for hanging out with us here on
the things